[Musique]
c'était avant-hier avant-hier dans une
ville japonaise à nagoya et vous allez
voir qu'on peut dire dans tous les sens
du terme que c'est dû c'est du jamais
joueurs là vous dites normalement il n'y
a pas de spectacle en ce moment tout le
monde cherche des idées pour faire des
spectacles distancié alors celui-ci vous
allez voir si vous êtes spectateur en
fait vous n'allez pas tout voir déjà
retrouvé deux ans iep hennissements je
commence à le regretter
découvrons ce que les femmes et les
hommes trouvent réellement attirant
c'est sympa c'est est-ce que choisir un
partenaire uniquement sur le physique ou
peut mieux faire
permettra de trouver le bon jeu si tu es
simplement parfait nous le saurons dans
cette émission lui quand j'y vas tu
choisir you take que la décision lui
procure de ma vie regardez ce que vous
voyez si vous êtes spectateur vous avez
l'impression d'espionner le spectacle
ont en tout cas d'en voir une partie
vous êtes installés dans des boxes
autour d'une scène circulaire est en
fait vous voyez le spectacle regarder
soi à travers un judas comme sur une
porte soit à travers la fente de la
taille d'une boîte aux lettres alors ses
prospections
7h40
ils sont amis tu as une bonne taille
c'est très bien kate sens là ça y est
importante
oui je dois dire qu'il ya un truc avec
verre tu peux très prochaine
ok quand pourquoi pas allons-y allons
inspecter inspectant la marchandise ils
étaient franchement ni de loin vous avez
slam et timothée vous a essayé j'ai
essayé mais battre quand je fais que
j'adore ça mais vous avez les bons mots
non je pense que j'aurais pu teint peu
sur des beats pour des beats
c'est bizarre comme phrase ça y est
c'est officiel le prince harry a retiré
le bal est son cul 9 points vider les
trous de balles
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
voilà voilà la séquence gérer pisser
chez vous à lui quand ils sont passés
par la maison du prince de bel air les
caméras ont suivi arrive jusqu'au petit
coin et regarder un prince ne ferme pas
lui même la porte des toilettes
will smith confirme moyens dans une
interview qu'il compte se lancer en
politique il veut faire entendre sa voix
différemment se rendre utile il fera
peut-être candidat à une future
présidentielle aux états unis en même
temps ça ne serait pas surprenant c'est
une forme de tradition aux états unis
arnold schwarzenegger est bien devenu
gouverneur de californie et puis un peu
plus loin ronald reagan est passé des
western wind sont blanches ya jamais eu
un moment où sur notre planète
la paix était partout présente
historiquement n'ai jamais eu jamais
dans nos oreilles qui forment pas non
non non non elle a toujours des conflits
il ya toujours des ddd des guerres des
menaces gansu mourir à tour et après
c'est son boulot et le défi c'est comme
ça et ça les arrange parce que c'est mon
boulot fait aussi ça malheureux mais
nous ne vais pas droit vous avez vu ce
restaurateur qui a été dénoncé par un de
ses voisins parce qu'ils organisaient
des déjeuners clandestins est-ce qu'il
faut dénoncer
et sur des noms sur dénonce pas on a une
culture qui braquait black ultime série
délit sébastien vous avez fait ça un
jour à votre chéri est même le meilleur
des avocats auraient pas fut plaidé en
votre faveur
c'était quoi je pense que c'est d'avoir
vendu son appartement chanson d'accord à
mal alors là on est sur la route sera là
en est sur un bon niveau là ça va tu me
fais peur quand tu fais des trucs comme
ça
mais si je faisais comme ça c'est parce
que j'ai une contraction qui s'est mal
bon on ne fait pas des têtes comme ça ça
mon stress quand tu fais des têtes pas
neutre et c'est de s'offrir en signe de
protestation
yannick a décidé de s'enchaîner en eau
du radar à 4 mètres du sol
je suis en train de le cadenasser
yannick c'est quoi que vous avez dans
les mains là bas ça c'est les
contraventions
les contraventions en fait ils ont
trouvé la recette idéale pour faire du
jackpot derrière le peuple français il
ya la mère de toutes ces âmes au delà de
toutes ces âmes
monsieur le président une nouvelle fois
c'est france gall qui vous parle je
crois aux forces de l'esprit président
[Musique]
il s'agit d'un horizon de plus en plus
proche peut-être nous l'espérons dès la
mi avril auquel nous nous préparons et
le président nous a demandé de présenter
des dispositifs et des protocoles qui
pourrait permettre de rouvrir prudemment
mais sûrement le pays dans les prochains
temps une réunion se tiendra à vous le
savez autant du président de la
république
cet après midi en ce sens la question
qui est devant nous est donc la suivante
alors que nous avons cet horizon en vue
par quels chemins l'atteignons de dax et
vexée bac 6 ans baby n'avait plus été vu
ces images hallucinantes nous viennent
d'europe du nord sur la côte de la
baltique près de la capitale finlandaise
helsinki des planchistes passionnés
fonce à toute allure sur la glace ce
sport de l'extrême n'est pas fait pour
les marmottes ceux qui aiment le froid
et la vitesse en revanche y trouveront
leur compte
c'est un drôle de sport d'hiver
forcément aisée vu ses jolies mains de
ceux qui préfèrent les sports d'été mais
version il est reparti pu dire et comme
quoi le patin ça roule merci il ya des
photos sur la page facebook est
d'ailleurs ce cas c'est rigolo
en tout cas moi j'ai bien ri quand tu
aller sur un site internet c'est qu'un
slogan qu'il dit l'art d'embellir donc
on voit qu'avec jacqueline c'est pas
vraiment le cas ce qui se dit en tout
cas jamais versé
je m'attendais et pour tout vous dire je
pète un peu même reculé de ma chaise
quand tu vas tellement rire ça s'appelle
un roman télé je pense que vous allez le
voir pendant dix ans dans tous les à
ping qui ont passé sur toutes les
chaînes
quand vous faites ce genre de blagues
aux fidji b comme elle réagit gens en
général
bon ben je pense que de faire rire tu
sais je suis tombé sur deux reprises
écoute bien haut son slogan c'est l'art
d'embellir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
puis moi j'aime ça va pas dans les
tailles d'artois olala mais qu'est ce
que j'ai à faire
j'ai littéralement repeint la chef d'art
aux autres ce que vous soulignez de
l'admirer après la publicité tient parce
qu'on est déjà d'accord ça vous
apprendra vous aviez